what is it that distinguishes us from
you know cavemen
I would say it's the level of
abstraction that we can reach and you
know to give a simple example it used to
be that there was barter trading so you
would exchange you know you know wheat
for for meat or something like this but
then eventually there was an abstract
idea the idea of money of illnesses like
piece of paper but this piece of paper
actually signifies has certain value and
you can exchange it for goods and
services so that's the next level of
abstraction but now we are dealing with
even higher level abstraction because we
don't actually see money that much I see
the piece of plastic credit card so I
swiped my credit card so suddenly that's
the next level of abstraction so this
credit card somehow has become this
abstract entity which carries money
which itself carries certain wealth
right and now we're going even deeper
now money could be nothing but a line of
code which appears in the Bitcoin ledger
so that's the kind of progression that's
the kind of you know evolution that I'm
talking about evolution of abstraction
and so abstraction is king in this brave
new world and the key to abstraction is
mathematics and I do believe that we
will have a better free society one when
we have less math ignorant and we have
less more understanding of mathematics
and of course I'm not saying everyone
should become a mathematician
on the contrary but what I would what I
dream of is a society in which if
mathematics is brought up people don't
run away from it it don't say oh my gosh
this is terrible I hate mathematics I
don't want to talk about it I'm scared
I'm frightened and I understand why
people are scared and frightened it's
not their fault
it's because of how mathematics is
taught in our schools but and it's a
very unfortunate situation when you
can't even begin a conversation about
mathematics without people saying oh my
gosh I don't wanna talk about it and
it's kind of strange because nobody
would ever say I hate literature or a
hit art or I hate music at least
intelligent people would never say that
it's kind of shameful to say that but
it's perfectly okay in our society to
say I
heat mathematics so so that's where I
think with so much work that can be done
and needs to be done and so what I dream
over the society in which not it's not
that everyone has a PhD in mathematics
but rather I would like to live in a
society in which if a mathematics is
brought up someone would say Oh
mathematics interesting how do I find
out more can you give me a gist of the
idea I'm not scared of it I'm curious
about it the way I'm curious about solar
system about the atoms in the DNA all
these things which are in our collective
consciousness in our public discourse
which are knows no simpler than
mathematical concepts mathematical
concepts are no more complicated than
these concepts in physics and biology
that are in the air that are that we are
aware of so I would like people to be
aware of this of Malthus mathematical
ideas I'd like them to be more and more
aware of how mathematics invades our
lives how its controlling our lives be
it through things we discussed earlier
or through things like algorithms that
we face when we go and buy a book on
Amazon or rent a movie on Netflix I mean
in all of these instances we are
presented with recommendations and
things like that
which are based on sophisticated
algorithms and I do believe that if we
understand better how Mad Max works how
Mad Max enters our lives we will be
better equipped to deal with the
challenges that you know this brave new
world presents to us
you